I'm still going to chase you back to
that story about both the PR company,
but I have another question for you.
So,
you know,
you,
you are detailing out the
kind of childhood that in
principle could have left
you bitter and resentful.
So why didn't it,
like,
why didn't that happen to you?
Why?
I think because of my father,
my mother was a deep pessimists.
My father was a profound optimist
and I must've had my father's genes
predominating over.
I got them both,
um,
optimism and pessimism.
But I'm grateful for everything
that's happened in my life.
I'm from every deprivation.
You know,
I was sick in bed for 15 years,
and even that turned out to be,
it was nightmarish.
It was horrible.
It inflicted pains for which there are
no words in the English language because
I was isolated for five
years and could not talk,
literally could not muster
the energy to move the larynx,
to give a single syllable of sound.
MMM.
And yet,
I as nightmarish,
horrible and monstrous does,
it was I,
I found it to international
scientific groups.
So at that time,
um,
I wrote three books,
uh,
and I learned what it's like to be at
that extreme of the human experience,
extreme isolation,
um,
extreme pain.
What happened to you?
What,
what were you suffering from?
Well,
we figured it out.
I mean,
I figured it out on my own and
then taught my doctor about it.
It's called chronic fatigue syndrome.
It's better sometimes known as Myalgic
encephalomyelitis and nobody knows what
causes it.
But in 1988,
I really have been working on my book,
um,
for a long enough to have fifth to
first 15 chapters of my first book.
I really wanted to get out of publicity.
There's no way I could've
because I was a legend.
I mean,
the billboard guy to music publicity
had 20 pages of nothing but me.
MMM.
So yeah,
you know,
your wife is not going to let
you out of a successful career.
And if she's,
she doesn't want to lose the money,
she doesn't want to lose the status.
Um,
and all of a sudden wank.
I didn't know what was happening to me.
It was 90 degrees out and I'd
be freezing and shivering.
Um,
it was 40 degrees out and
I would be overheated.
Um,
I was,
I was losing strengths.
I was losing the strength
to pick up coach.
Hmm.
MMM.
And I had no idea of what was happening.
And I went to doctors and the doctors
had no idea of what was happening.
And I walked into my office one day,
it was the biggest PR firm in the
music industry and said to my staff,
I don't know what's happening.
I could be dying,
but I'm going to be out of here in two
weeks and I'm giving you the business.
And the next day,
a competitor from the west coast called
and offered me a huge amount of money
for the business.
And I said,
I cannot sell it to you.
I just gave it to my staff yesterday
because my word is my bond.
And,
um,
I kept trying to,
struggling to try to do normal things.
Leon Uris.
When I finished my
manuscript of the first book,
the Lucifer principle of scientific
expedition into the forces of history,
I got a copy to Leon Uris,
the novelist and Leon Uris read it and
called on a Sunday night and raved about
it for half an hour.
Um,
so I tried to get it
to New York to see him,
but I had a rent.
Are you ready for this?
Cause I couldn't afford this.
I had a rental Lilo so I could lay
down in the back seat all the way into
Manhattan to see Leon and then lay
down in the back seat all the way home.
That's not the world's most
glamorous limousine story.
Now it's not at all the world's
most glamorous limousines for any.
Eventually I learned I couldn't even do
that and eventually it became too weak
to even try because I was just lucky
to be able to get to my bathroom.
But if I tried to get to my
kitchen and extra 10 steps away,
no,
my body wouldn't let me do it.
And one of the lessons I
learned in my childhood,
again,
when I was 16 years old,
poetry was extremely important to me.
And I learned a lesson from two poets.
One was at the Saint Vincent Millay
and her poem Renascence said to see the
infinite and the tiniest of things,
which was definitely a goal on my list.
You have to be able to comprehend the
suffering of every human on the face of
this planet under every
extreme circumstance.
And I expanded that to mean you have
to come to understand not just the
suffering,
but the point of view of everyone who
comes from a culture that's so foreign
tiers that it seems like
was from another planet.
So this was what,
what Edna Saint Vincent Millay was
telling me was 15 years of absolute and
unbelievable punishment is an advantage
and it will serve you well for the rest
of your life.